foreign
with the MPC on ESPN
what's up what happened there oh that
was amazing man we got a chance to uh
join the uh ESPN studio today me and
musty was making beats right there live
you know I'm saying they ain't really
seen that but you know the tour is
coming soon you know you guys go on tour
you guys pull out the NPC that before
fmg
I remember I saw Jurassic 5 do that for
the first time when I was a kid uh cut
chemist and DJ Newmark pulled out the
[ __ ] NPC that [ __ ] blew my mind man
you and mustard did that together yeah
we did that today on ESPN it was
legendary yeah shout out to all my ESPN
fam and uh we got the
song as well uh we did a collab with the
NBA so basically every game you gonna
hear it you know what I'm saying like I
said the most important song right now I
did a remix the NBA version the ESPN
version you know I'm about to do the
bootleg cab version we out here are you
gonna do some uh some dub plates for the
DJs of course that's the most important
you know next to the fans shout out to
all my DJs out there